the Lost Woods is a mysterious and
magical forest that has made several
appearances throughout the zelda
franchise
it's a vast expanse of mist and forestry
home to mystical characters the Deku
Tree and even the fabled Master Sword
itself these wondrous would seem at
first glance to be a harmless set of
puzzles for the hero to uncover but in a
certain game were given an insight into
the other less innocent side of the Lost
Woods it is said in the game ocarina of
time that those who wander into the
woods will become lost within and
experience a dark fate far worse than
the sting of death it is said that souls
unfortunate enough to be enticed into
the woodland will forever walk the earth
and become the accursed undead
but why would the same forest that
houses the righteous blade of Evil's
Bane and the benevolent childlike forest
spirits destroy innocent souls like this
and how would they be changed here to
join me today on this frightful night as
my good friend and fellow Zelda tuber
the Hyrule gamer I'll have links to his
channel and our other collaboration
project that's actually live right now
in the description so please be sure to
check him and our other video out right
after we're done here and now without
further ado let's delve right in to the
horrors of being lost in the woods
these daunting woodlands may appear
relatively safe and inviting at first
glance but take a few steps into the
omnious mist invade new on n and you'll
be in for a surprise the Lost Woods have
appeared many times for a Zelda series
from but not limited to a Link to the
Past breath of the wild a link between
worlds and arguably its most noble
appearance coming in ocarina of time
these woods can be found connected to
the magical haven of a village in Kokiri
Forest oh you'll discover by talking to
the residents of the forest that even
the children of the peaceful and magical
village know the dangers these woods
contain the Lost Woods is almost like a
maze something that you'd think is just
another harmless Zelda puzzle but think
again these dark and chilling woods are
a giant never-ending maze a maze
designed to trap you inside with no
escape a cryptic labyrinth looking for
victims to capture for as many
appearances in the series link will run
into enemies such as fees or bandits as
well waffles and Deku scrubs but it's
not just the enemies that this spooky
location holds as well as enemies we can
also find some very iconic sites like
the Temple of Time and Twilight Princess
although is within the sacred grove in
Twilight Princess the area that is north
of the Lost Woods in a Link to the Past
along with being the location we find
this sacred Master Sword hidden away
deep within the woodlands as mysterious
and weird as all of that is the loss
would told a much darker much deeper
scarier and to be quite honest with you
a much more chilling secret The Lost
Woods have this painting lean and
horrifying ability to turn the souls of
innocent people even but mere children
into the Living Dead thus tell foes
which is what we call the cursed
bloodthirsty undead were once mortal
beings no different than link himself
their minds became slowly corrupted
until all they could think of is murder
of the living their skin rotted until it
completely fell off they suffered this
fate for nothing but the crime of
becoming law
among the trees so why would the woods
change them into unholy skeletal demons
with seemingly no reason for doing so
what makes those souls any different and
why did the same not happen to link is
this some tragic mistake
divine intervention in ocarina of time
we can gather some clues as to why this
happens one of the steps of the games
trading sequence for the big or on sword
involves waking up a strange lone figure
in the middle of the lost woods named
grog who was shown to be alone sleeping
up against a stump this man will only
wake up when his Kaku named kojirou
crows nearby when that happens he will
then instruct link to take a mushroom
found within the Lost Woods to a witch
to be made into a potion but when link
returns with the potion he's nowhere to
be found
and the little Kokiri girl named fado
will be waiting for you in his stead she
says that grog has become lost within
the woods leaving only his saw behind
she says that grog has become a stalfos
and that everyone who becomes lost
within the woods becomes a stalfos but
this can't be completely true because if
link becomes lost within the game he
will simply exit the woods after too
long with or without the triforce of
courage so what's the difference here a
possible explanation to this is a theory
that was brought to my attention from my
discord member named Kyle cloud his
theory states that the well-known song
and theme of the Lost Woods known to us
as sir I assume is actually what
transforms the living into the undead
within the woods some evidence to back
this theory is that if you reverse the
song it actually creates another song we
know very well the song of healing from
a jaws mask
given that Majora's Mask proves to us
that if we reverse magical songs we can
actually create other effects from them
what if sir I assume which is the
inverse of the song of healing instead
of healing drains the life or curses
those who hear it some things that would
cause this theory to be questioned would
be that the hero link is able to hear
the song and is seemingly unaffected by
it and the Goron darunia simply dances
at the catchy tune but the theory does
provoke some serious thought another
theory is what if the
creators of the Lost Woods who are more
than likely either the great Deku Tree
or the golden goddess Ferrari herself
purposefully cursed the woods to guard
what's inside
we know the woods hold the Master Sword
and even the temple of time deep within
its trees but what would happen if
either of those fell subject to the
forces of darkness the Master Sword can
indeed drain the life of a wielder where
they stand if deemed unworthy but what
about against the dark magic of demise
himself could the sword really stand up
to that the unfortunate man named grog
from ocarina of time was shown to be a
lazy fool who inexplicably ran away from
home could it be that the curse is meant
to destroy mortal intruders with
darkness in their hearts by turning them
into the undead much like the Triforce
which will split itself if a mortal with
an unbalanced heart touches it could
this forest behave the same way this may
be evidenced by the fact that the boss
of the Forest Temple is phantom Ganon
which is to say a false Ganondorf
Ganondorf himself does not appear to
have stepped foot with in the woods for
fear of being transformed by him it's
only his monsters and minions that have
the theory that the darkness within
one's heart will forever transform them
within the woods is further evidenced by
what is perhaps the darkest and most
disturbing part of the Lost Woods enter
the Skull Kid these scarecrow looking
children are the results of a horrifying
process that happens within the Lost
Woods Oh only with certain circumstances
can these shadow looking amps come about
the skull could stick on an interesting
and unique appearance made up with a
straw out there Brown cloak in ha
accompanied by a flute they will play
making them seem friendly in
high-spirited but don't be fooled these
innocent but yeah unsettling looking
children are no ordinary beatings the
school kids are actually Kokiri yeah
that's right
the playful and joyful children of the
forest are absolutely the creepy ghostly
Skull kids let me explain why as far as
common knowledge in Hyrule goes it's
known that anyone who wanders into the
Lost Woods for too long will turn into a
Schnauzer stall child which is true but
not for the Kokiri the kukuri children
who inhabit the magical Woodlands
neighboring the Lost Woods are a special
but yet truly terrible
and horrifying case in ocarina of time
fairy tales link that the Kokiri
children do not turn into stalfos the
reason being is that turning into
Stavros is a process of dying going from
a living being to the Living Dead
but the Kokiri are eternally children
and there is no stopping that they can't
die it's not possible so instead of
turning into a snow child they me a much
more daunting fate they turn into skull
kids another thing to know is the
connection between both the Kokiri and
the skull kids the kukuri went on to
eventually evolve into the core ox
further down in the timeline and we can
clearly see that they are made of wood
and also wear a mask traits similar to
the Skull Kid who is made of wood and
also wears a mask but this dark truth
goes deeper than simple appearances in
ocarina of time there is a cookery child
who's said to be unhappy with their face
these are quote from the game bean what
weird face speaking of weird faces one
of the forest kids was complaining about
his face now this is where it gets
really dark that child was unhappy with
their appearance could barely live with
themselves knowing what they look like
all the way to the point of possibly
being suicidal and becoming a hermit
locking himself away from the world
well that geek eerie child went off into
the Lost Woods thoroughly knowing the
damage and horror they would bring to
themself that child made the conscious
decision to end their time as a kaki REE
and pass on to be a skull kids Navi the
fairy tales link in the game that the
scope kid you see in front of you seems
unhappy to not have a face you end up
giving him a mass to hide his own face
confirming that this used to be the
Kokiri child's spoken off earlier in the
game what makes this even more sad and
honestly unsettling is that it's known
that the core ox specifically are too
scared to even go near the Lost Woods
this info was given to us in breath of
the wild through the lost pilgrimage
site quest it's not unlikely that they
have always been this way
scared frightened and warned of the
dangers of the Lost Woods but yet that
banca kiri child had the darkness in his
heart and willpower to walk into the
Lost Woods so what about you as schools
and spirits haunt
living this Halloween would you be
worthy of entering the woods alone or
would you be turned into a creature of
the night cursed forever to wander the
woods in search of your next kill hey
thank you so much for watching leave us
a like if you enjoyed watching and
comment down below letting us know what
you think subscribe now to mass antennae
bandit if you haven't already for much
more juicy content to come and to hyrule
gamer for more of his amazing zelda
theories and insights thanks a ton for
having me on this video it has been a
blast as always to work with vanta be
sure to go and check us out in another
video we did over my channel covering
the dark and terrifying truth behind
Hyrule Field in ocarina of time again
thanks for having me and until the next
time I've been high roll gamer as usual
I asked you guys a few days ago if you
could guess the text in my thumbnail
teaser and guess what you did right off
the bat again and this time it was a
dead tie because I honestly don't know
which one of you came first somebody got
it right on discord and somebody got it
right on YouTube at the exact same time
so from YouTube congratulations Ben
Huckabee you got it right off the bat if
you're watching this right now go ahead
and give us a comment and over on the
discord side of things mr. Tibor and
Sculptra is the one who guessed it right
off the bat as well so congratulations
to the both of you go ahead and give us
some victory comments down below as
always huge thank you to my patreon
supporters for doing what they do and
making videos like this possible
including my newest supporter Turner
Myles if you're interested in joining
the elite supporters of the channel and
being recognized at the end of every
video check out the link in the
description below also the link to my
amazing discord server is located down
there as well so if you like Zelda and
have a discord then really what are you
waiting for join us as we discuss the
greatest of Zelda topics over in discord
that's all I've got for you today so
please remember to stay safe all you
trick-or-treaters out there hope you
have an especially spooky Halloween this
year
this is mess than an abandoned
signing out peace
[Music]